hey 42 here i'm not sure if you've ever
noticed but newborn humans are on the
whole utterly useless a baby giraffe can
walk within half an hour of it being
born only minutes after hatching turtles
are able to crawl down an entire beach
and then swim away into the ocean
depending on the species it can take as
little as two weeks for a bird to be
able to fly not walk
fly
our species on the other hand spends the
first thousand hours of our lives doing
absolutely nothing
we're completely helpless
faced with some form of existential
threat our best defense
is to shut ourselves
it's all a little embarrassing really
to make matters even more challenging
one in 10 humans are born prematurely
which can dramatically increase the
difficulties they need to overcome as
infants nowadays many of these issues
are treatable and miraculously a child
born a full three months early has a 90
chance of survival but it wasn't always
this way 100 years ago if your baby was
born prematurely
things were bleak
in fact there was pretty much only one
thing you could do to give them any
chance of surviving at all take them to
the carnival
if you visited new york in the early
part of the 20th century the place to go
for some laughs was coney island at the
time the largest entertainment area in
the united states with millions of
visitors every year and three separate
amusement parks coney island was a
chaotic blend of hot dog stands roller
coaster rides animal exhibitions side
shows and displays of the weird and the
wonderful
people came to be entertained and amazed
by everything from bearded ladies to the
latest advances in electrical lighting
but
nestled in the middle of this madness
was a strange blend of science and
spectacle an exhibit called the
infantorium made up of a collection of
glass incubators displaying premature
human babies
visitors paid 25 cents to enter the
sterile environment staffed by a team of
qualified nurses all dressed up in white
that all sounds pretty weird but despite
being located in the middle of an
amusement park the inventorium was
probably the most advanced neonatal care
unit in the entire country
the man responsible for creating this
bizarre infant oasis was dr martin
cooney a prussian immigrant who began
his career in europe in the late 19th
century before moving to the united
states
in those days there was very little
medical understanding of how to treat a
baby born prematurely preemies as they
were called were basically wrapped up
warm and then their parents were left to
hope for the best
but the best was seldom the result
death rates amongst premature babies
were extremely high
then in the 1880s a french obstetrician
by the name of etienne tarnier had a
flash of insight after a visit to paris
zoo
there he noticed the incubation chambers
used to keep eggs warm until they
hatched and he decided to build his own
child hatchery using a similar approach
these incubators were of a fairly basic
design intended to roughly mimic the
conditions of a mother's uterus with the
idea being that the babies within could
continue to grow as though they'd never
left the womb
tania's work was rejected by mainstream
medical establishment as pseudoscience
which was a bit rich considering that
around the same time the accepted
treatment for chickenpox was to take
laxatives
but another french doctor pierre boudon
was a passionate supporter of tania's
work and decided the best way to get the
word out was some direct marketing
at the berlin world's fair in 1896
boudon displayed six premature babies in
glass incubation chambers to an
astonished public and the exhibit turned
out to be a runaway success
the man who helped boudon achieve those
results was his student
martin cooney who saw the chance to take
this technology to a much wider audience
over the next few years he featured his
baby display at fairs exhibitions and
world expos in london paris omaha new
york portland mexico city rio de janeiro
denver san francisco chicago and
atlantic city
but it was coney island that was
destined to become the infantorium
spiritual home and in 1903 cooney
established a permanent exhibition there
that would remain for 40 years
cooney's methods were unconventional but
progressive
babies were either fed using a unique
feeding technique through the nose or by
wet nurses who in turn were cooked for
by dedicated chefs to ensure they got
the right nutrition
nurses weren't allowed to smoke eat junk
food or drink alcohol
cooney also insisted that the working
environment for all nurses was as
relaxing as possible believing that
stress had a negative impact on their
performance and the quality of care they
offered the babies
contrary to some popular thinking at the
time
nurses were encouraged to take the
babies out of their incubators and
cuddle them in the belief that human
touch helps them recover more quickly
obviously not everyone saw things
cooney's way
putting the babies under his care on
display in the middle of a theme park
quite understandably triggered outcries
from child protection groups who said
cooney was exploiting the babies and
their parents
whilst one of the major medical journals
at the time condemned him for using the
inventorium as a thinly veiled excuse to
line his own pockets
there was also that not insignificant
issue that there wasn't actually any
evidence cooney was even a real doctor
he claimed to have studied medicine in
leipzig germany but no one was ever able
to find records to prove it
so
was this man really just a fraud
cynically using vulnerable children as
marketing tools to fleece cash from the
gullible and the curious
well
the results
say no
cooney may not have been a certified
medical doctor and yeah he may have set
up his child care facility next door to
the elephant man
but he clearly got something right
at a time when actual doctors in real
hospitals failed to save 90
of pre-term infants
a remarkable 90 percent of the babies
entrusted to cooney's care
survived it's estimated he and his
nurses saved the lives of as many as 7
000 premature babies over the first half
of the 20th century
and just in case there were any
lingering doubts about his motives it
turns out cooney never charged the
parents
a single cent
it was definitely pretty unorthodox to
put premature babies on display whilst
they were being nursed back to health
but by charging the public to see the
exhibition
cooney was able to make enough money to
cover all the costs of caring for the
children while still paying his nurses a
decent wage
initially the people who benefited the
most from it were the poor unable to
afford any kind of private medical
treatment and with so few public
hospitals equipped with incubators
disadvantaged parents were able to
access free care at cooney's infantorium
with severely premature babies that was
literally the difference between life
and death
even during the great depression of the
1930s when poverty skyrocketed cooney's
treatments remained free saving
thousands of lives
on its own the story of martin cooney
and the many babies he saved
would be extraordinary
but what really makes it stand out is
the cultural climate that surrounded it
in america the start of the 20th century
saw the rise of eugenics a belief in the
need to weed out of the weak or unworthy
from the human population
leaving behind a pristine gene pool of
humans that were smart strong and
good-looking
this type of thinking led to compulsory
sterilization laws being introduced in
30 u.s states
under these laws tens of thousands of
americans particularly those of ethnic
minorities were forcibly sterilized in
order to eliminate so-called undesirable
characteristics from the population
through the warped lens of eugenics
premature babies who were naturally
weaker and sicklier than their full-term
peers
were essentially considered a liability
to the human race
articles in medical journals at the time
condemned cooney's attempts to save
these babies saying they would pass on
their deficiencies deformities and vices
to the next generation
fortunately the popularity of eugenics
slowly died out by the middle part of
the 20th century when it became a
favorite pastime of a little gang of
psychopaths called the nazis
but people like martin cooney had
resisted it all the way through
at the 1933 chicago world's fair
cooney shared an exhibition space with a
eugenics organization committed to
preventing what it called undesirable
births
one of the publicity campaigns for the
eugenicists involved hosting pageants
called better baby contests
designed to showcase the healthiest and
most beautiful babies around
in a classic backfire one of these
better baby winners tragically died of
tuberculosis a few months after the fair
on the other hand an infant that had
been brought to dr coney in a shoe box
around the same time went on to live to
80 years old despite his amazing results
in child care cooney's reputation was
always a little sketchy
hardly surprising given his inability to
prove that he was actually a qualified
doctor
the medical establishment constantly
criticized the fact that his inventorium
was located amongst animal exhibits and
peep shows apparently making it
physically and morally unhygienic
cooney's case wasn't helped by the
impostor shows that began popping up
around the united states
many of these exhibitions copied
cooney's model of putting live babies on
display
but didn't deliver the same levels of
cleanliness and medical treatment
some even used perfectly healthy babies
who were not premature at all
sparking fears that a side industry of
baby production would grow
with parents hiring out their children
to carnival sideshows
that never came to pass but in 1911
cooney's credibility took a major blow
when a fire broke out at one of the
coney island entertainment centers
all the infants were rescued but the
incident convinced many that it probably
wasn't a great idea to have babies
hanging around in amusement parks after
all
yeah maybe that wasn't such a bad thing
despite the skepticism cooney's
undeniably brilliant results did
eventually win over much of the medical
community with local physicians
entrusting their own patients whose
babies were born prematurely to him
today coney is seen as one of the
pioneers of early infant care someone
who publicized premature births at a
time when mainstream science refused to
talk about them and a courageous
opponent of the eugenics movement
despite being a little bit dodgy he
saved thousands of lives and gave hope
to people who couldn't afford medical
care for their children plus he sported
a pretty decent mustache so in my book
he's a bit of a hero
thanks for watching